so let's continue this batch rendering
party last time we took a look at what
batch rendering actually was we did a
bit of theory and put together a basic
example of just rendering two squares
check out that video if you missed it
today we're going to continue on with
kind of filling in the blanks of what we
could do with traditional rendering
which we can't do with batch rendering
and kind of bringing all of those
features I guess back into it so last
time we did just draw two wide quads two
white squares and that was fine
obviously but eventually you're probably
gonna want to do other things for
example draw quads of different colors
or draw textured quads or dynamically
change the quads that are being drawn
all those things and that's exactly what
this miniseries is about what kind of
going through everything step by step
breaking it down doing it in a really
kind of simple way and then filling in
everything that we would want to
actually achieve with bash rendering so
today that's going to be all about color
how do we draw two quads of different
colors or in fact any number of quads
with different colors traditionally when
we want to draw a colored quad if you
think about like the the most simplest
way I mean the simplest way is probably
quite subjective something that might be
simple to me might not be simple to you
you might think something else is simple
but when I think of like let's just
render required a colored quad a flat
colored quad in the most basic way
possible what I think of is simply
filling in a vertex buffer with the
vertex positions and then rendering that
quad and then in the fragment shader
passing in some kind of uniform variable
which contains the color of course we
could just hard code the fragment shader
to be a particular color but that
wouldn't really be useful if we have two
different quads we'd have to write two
different shaders or something like that
instead of that what we would do is just
render our quad twice using two
different draw calls but then have a
uniform like Veck for vector e color
inside our fragment shader which we
would set the output color to be and
then that would actually be kind of set
up before the draw will happen so I can
just use like Jail uniform 3f or gel
uniform for F and actually set those
variables before drawing my quad before
actually calling GL draw elements that's
kind of to me what would be the the
simplest way of rendering a quad however
we can't do that anymore and the reason
we can't do that anymore is because we
just have one draw
we can't call GL uniform for F than Geo
draw elements and then call gel uniform
for up again and then draw elements
because we just we when they have one
elements call we only have one draw
elements call so we can't set the
uniform to be two different values
between draws what do we do now there
are a number of solutions to this you
did I mean you could have like an array
of color values and you could kind of
pass in the index and like there's a lot
of different things you could do some of
them better than others but the way that
we're gonna solve it in this video is
what I think is probably the best way to
solve it I mean subjectively of course
just my opinion no need to get mad and
that is by using vertex colors now you
may have heard of vertex colors before
so let's just talk a little bit about
what that actually means currently our
vertex simply contains a position so
every vertex just has three floats X Y Z
and that defines the position of that
vertex but positions are not the only
things that vertices are capable of
containing and in fact vertex and vertex
position is often used interchangeably
which isn't exactly correct for example
someone might refer to the vertices of
an object and really be talking about
the vertex positions of an object
however the word vertex and what it
actually means in graphics programming
is simply a point which can contain as
much data as you really want it to do
you could store absolutely anything
inside of vertex and then access that
data inside your vertex shader so that's
what we're going to do today every
single vertex that we actually have
inside our vertex buffer is going to
contain a color and then we're going to
access that color from within the vertex
buffer inside our vertex shader pass it
to the fragment shader and then set that
as our output color so since each vertex
now contains a color obviously every
chord has the ability to be any color we
set it to and in fact it's even finer
grain than that we can actually control
the color of every vertex thus creating
like a gradient or something like that
if we would want to do that just relying
on interpolation between the vertex and
the fragment shaders but anyway that's
the story for another day so to break
this down all we're gonna do today is
just open up our vertex buffer and just
add a color into every
and then access that inside our shader
and set that as our output color is as
simple as that does no need to
complicate things let's dive into the
code and take a look so at the moment we
have these two white squares from the
previous video let's give them some
color let's come over here to our vertex
buffer which currently contains just the
vertex positions of these two squares
and let's add some colors here maybe
like a blue and a yellow so for this
first quad let's make it a nice blue
color we'll add the values here red
green blue and alpha now this gives us a
color for this vertex but since we want
the entire quad to be one solid color
we'll need to copy this color across all
of these four vertices which make up our
square now let's come down here to our
second quad and we'll make it a nice
yellow color I'll add in the RGB a
values for all the vertices which make
up that second Square and that's it we
have our two squares with the first
three floats of each vertex are the XYZ
position of that vertex and then the
next four floats of each vertex are the
RGB a color values and that's it that's
all of our data going down here the only
thing I need to change is the vertex
attribute declarations we have here
since we changed our vertex buffer
layout what we're doing here is treating
the first attribute attribute 0 as the
position and we don't want to change
that but what we want to do is add
another attribute which is going to be
index 1 and that's gonna be our color
it's going to be 4 floats
RGBA and then the other thing that
changes here is the stride the stride is
how many bytes are complete vertex is so
here we have seven floats per vertex so
we can just change both of these to
seven and finally this is the offset of
that attribute which starts at the
fourth float of our vertex so this is
our vertex what is the size of these
three floats three floats are 12 bytes
so we can just write in 12 and cast it
into a Const word pointer because that's
what the API wants and that's it that's
all we have to do C++ side then we just
render it as usual we've got those
colors in the vertex buffer so now what
we need to do is modify our shader so
that it will use these vertex colors at
the moment we've just got this layout
location equals zero of x3 position
which is the position of our
and what we need is another one of these
but at location 1 because index 1 is
what we set our attribute to be and this
is going to be our vac for color now
color isn't very useful in a vertex
shader what we want to do is use this
color to shade all of our pixels width
so we need it in our fragment shader the
way we do that is create this output
color variable I'll call it V underscore
color V for varying which is what these
variables used to be called and we'll
set it equal to a color just like that
and that inside the fragment shader I'm
gonna take in that V color variable and
then I'll set our output color to be
that V color and that's it now let's
launch this and see what we get and
there we go we have our beautiful colors
shout-out to my Ukrainian fans here with
these colors but anyway that's what we
do to set different colors for our quads
even though they're batch together into
a single draw so yeah as I mentioned
super simple stuff vertex colors are
used not just for quads or 2d rendering
but also for 3d rendering for example we
don't necessarily need to render a 3d
model with a texture if we just want
that 3d model to be like a solid color
or different sub models kind of sub
meshes within that model to be different
colors or something like that if we're
going with something like a low poly
style game or something that just
doesn't need textures and textures and
stuff like that something that can just
rely on color so vertex colors are
definitely widely used not just for 2d
rendering keep that in mind but in this
case they're really really useful in a
very easy quick way to set up the color
of each quad if we're dealing with like
a batch kind of scenario like we are
with batch rendering but anyway I hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
please hit that like button and also
leave a comment with your thoughts below
also I do have a patreon patreon on
convoy slash the channel huge thank you
to everyone who supports me on patreon
because you are what make these kinds of
videos possible next time we're gonna be
talking about textures so we've covered
colors and that's great but what if I
want each of my quads to be a different
texture
so maybe I'm rendering a tile map and I
need water tiles brass tiles
maybe I'm rendering a label with text
and I need each quad to be a different
character how do I do all of that how do
we deal with different textures inside a
batch scenario we're gonna talk about
that next time I will see you then good
bye
[Music]
you
[Music]